in this video you're going to learn how
to convert from degrees to radians and
radians to degrees and we're going to go
through four examples together so the
first thing that you want to know and to
memorize is that Pi radians
is equal to 180 degrees or you could say
180 degrees is equal to Pi radians
they're equivalent and so we're going to
use that fact to convert from one unit
measure to another unit measure now say
we're given an angle here in radians
like pi over 20. what we do is we
multiply by a 180 degrees divided by pi
and the reason we set it up this way is
because 180 and Pi are really the same
so anything divided by itself is one and
then one times this fraction it doesn't
change the value it just changes the
units so it's going to change the way
that it looks
and the other reason we set it this way
is because the pi in the denominator is
going to cancel with the pi in the
numerator here so that goes in there one
time and when we multiply now we can say
1 times 180 is 180. 20 times 1 is 20.
and 20 goes into 180 nine times so it's
9 degrees so what this means is pi over
20 radians is equivalent to 9 degrees
now let's do a problem in the other way
now say they're giving us the angle in
degrees but we want to convert it into
radians so how do we do that what we're
going to do is we're going to multiply
by a conversion factor but in this case
we're going to write it as Pi
over 180. now the reason we set this up
this way instead of 180 over Pi is so
that the degree units in the denominator
will cancel with the degree units in the
numerator and you can think of 110 as
like 110 over one anything divided by 1
is itself
you can do a little bit more cross
reducing here you could say 10 goes into
110 11 times and 10 goes into 180 18
times so now when you multiply the
numerators together and denominators
together you're getting 11 pi over 18.
radians and you got it let's look at
another example so
here we're given radians now you might
be saying Mario how do you know that
this is in radians well you'll know if
it's in degrees because you'll see that
little degree unit symbol if it doesn't
have that then you know that it's going
to be in radians and so when you set
this up you're going to set it up like
180 divided by pi this way the pi in the
denominator cancels with the pi in the
numerator and we're left with the units
which we want which are the degrees so
it's kind of like a dimensional analysis
or unit conversions
now you can do some more reducing top
and bottom or on the diagonals so here I
can see that 18 goes in here once 18
goes in here
10 times and then when I multiply across
5 times 10 is 50 degrees and you got it
okay last example see if you can try
this one we're going from degrees 36
degrees to radians so what do we want to
multiply by here
well you're going to set this up as
times 1 over 180 and the reason I chose
this instead of the reciprocal is that
so the degree units in the denominator
cancel with the degree units in the
numerator and we're going to be left
with pi radians now I can do a little
bit more reducing here 36 goes in here
once 30 goes 36 goes into 185 times then
when I multiply the numerators together
I get pi and 1 times 5 is 5. so this is
going to be pi over 5 radians so great
job if you're able to follow these
examples now if you're wondering
what exactly is a radian and you want to
understand that at a deeper level follow
me over to that video I did right there
talking about radians and how we
actually think about radians I'll see
you in that video